That GPT is one of the fastest growing
fastest growing apps in history. But
with hundreds of millions of people
using this every day, has no one stopped
to ask why is this app so confusing?
Now let's demonstrate that with a
conversation. I have chat GBT pulled up
and we actually see two buttons to
interact with voice. This is the
voicetoext option and this is voice to
voice. Hey, OpenAI. How's it going? Hey
there. I'm doing great. Thanks for
asking. How about you? What's new on
your end? Sounds pretty good with a
little bit of vocal fry, but let's try
something a little bit more descriptive.
I want you to write a group email just
saying, "I'm super excited for the AI
Engineer World's Fair and I want to meet
up for lunch sometime."
Sure thing. How about something like
this? Excited for the AI Engineer Worlds
Fair? Let's meet for lunch. I'm super
excited about the upcoming AI Engineer
Worlds Fair. It does respond with a
nicely worded email, but it can only
respond through voice. If you want to
collaborate on the written email, the
best you can do is end the call and look
for a voice transcript with the nice
formatting at the end. Ideally, this
would be something multimodal with text
and voice together, but it really feels
like these two apps were built by two
different companies. Scott Hansselman
called this shipping the org chart,
which he explained really well, talking
about sitting in an EV. I'm looking at
the map and then I turn and I'm looking
at the climate thing and then I'm
looking at the speedometer and they're
all different fonts and then I realized
it was three Android tablets chained
together and I could suddenly see the
organ organizational chart of this large
international auto company and OpenAI is
guilty of this as well. You have some
whiz kid who ships a technical
improvement. It turns out it's exactly
what consumers are craving. Marketing's
never consulted and you end up with a
science fair full of potential options
like 03 4 Xbox 3601 Series S Pro. You
get the picture. So, let's see how to
fix it. There's two things I want to
change about chat GPT today. allowing
voice and text at the same time and
smartly choosing the right model
depending on your ask. And we can do
this with off-the-shelf tools. 40
Realtime gives you a live audio chat and
tool calls can handle the rest. You can
ask it to send a text for longer details
like links and drafts. And maybe a
research tool could hand off to a
smarter model and come back with an
answer. Let's bring this concept to
life. We have our voice button that
takes us from our dormant state to voice
mode which works exactly the same
floating orb at all. You have your mute,
your end call, and also a new button for
chat. This pulls up a panel that looks
like iMessage. It kind of feels like
texting your friend while you're on a
FaceTime call with your call controls at
the top, a little reminder of what you
might have asked if you're looking
through history, and then a text
response in case it needs more detail
for an email draft. Now what if we want
to ask something that requires more
detail? This is something we explore at
warp terminal which is a developer tool
to write code in any environment. I have
a project pulled up here and I can ask
it for simple things like undo my last
commit. This hands off to a coding agent
and decides to help me out by running
commands in my terminal. It can also
handle more complex questions though
like refactor this entire codebase to
use Flutter instead. it detects that
it's complex and decides to write a plan
with the reasoning model to make sure
the code actually works. This is a
really effective pattern that you can do
with some heristics. If you asked for
details and pros and cons, for example,
we could hand off to reasoning, tell you
how long it's thinking, and hand back a
more detailed response. Now, let's go
build it using off-the-shelf APIs. Hey
there, how's it going? Hey there, I'm
doing well, thank you. How about you?
How's your day going? Pretty good. I
just landed in California. Can you send
me a link to a park that I should go
visit? Of course. I'll send you a link
to a popular park in California. Yeah,
I've heard about Yuseite. Can you tell
me more about its history? Go deep.
Yoseite National Park's history is rich,
beginning with its ancient Native
American heritage and leading to its
establishment as a national park. Check
the chat for more details. And I'm
handling text input just using tool
calls. So we have this send chat message
tool where you send details that are
easier to explain via text. Didn't even
need a system prompt. Just added this
description and it was smartly able to
send the right stuff with text. It's
honestly amazing how far you can go with
very simple prompts these days. And for
reasoning models, we have another tool
called this is sending off. Whenever a
user wants to go deeper on a topic, you
can send some details and then respond
back to the model with whatever it needs
to say or just dump it straight in the
client if you're building an app like
this. If you want to see the source
code, it's available on my GitHub under
fix gpt. With that, subscribe and enjoy
the rest of the conference.